i would love to see sporting events with
twitch chat like can you imagine how fun
the olympics would have been
if it was streamed on twitch well it's
funny if you say that because i recently
someone in my twitch chat notified me of
this twitch channel that streams the
sumo on twitch
and okay dead ass there are people every
time one of them wins
there is dead ass just a stream of pog
that happens and i'm just like
this is weird that people are pogging a
sumo wrestler i'll be like [ __ ]
professional backseat is coming out
being like you know i assume wrestle for
ten years
you know this technique's pretty [ __ ]
lackluster here's how i would have
optimized that
obviously this is just sloppy behavior
dude i saw a clip that popped up on my
youtube as well and it was like
twitch chat goes crazy about car
stopping what
and it was just like a camera that's
watching a street with a stop sign
yeah and like a security camera yeah
yeah
and they're just streaming it and you
see twitch chat in the corner and no one
stops the stop sign
but then one car stops to the stop sign
and twitch checker is [ __ ] crazy
i'm just like who's watching this why is
there hundreds of people watching this
going crazy that's really funny
i feel like it's the equivalent of do
you remember the dvd
logo on like on like the dvd screen
and then like it hit it in the corner
actually is there a stream of that that
probably will i
i bet that would be very [ __ ] there
is a stream of that
i can because i can imagine when when
the dvd thing hits the corner the amount
of pogs in chat now the amount of pogs
in chat
every time it's so close it's like oh
monkeys
but not like yeah going back to twitch
plays pokemon like part of
part of the amazing experience of that
was being
like being part of something bigger and
i just i just
loved the law that that came out twitch
plays pokemon right
you went on the subreddit and everything
like that i wasn't on the subreddit
okay so there's like factions forming
against each other you know
yeah yeah so what happened is you know
you it was a random game played by
twitch chat or not randomly it was like
it was like a game played by a lot of
people and a lot of random things
happened yeah
and out of this randomness like
the community just created a kind of
storyline and they created a narrative
out of the
chaos that was happening right yes they
did and so and we're going full circle
now because an entire law
was created out of the chaos and the
randomness that was happening on twitch
plays pokemon
right right and and so part like people
got invested
in this narrative people got super super
[ __ ] invested in this law
god um the helix fossil and the helix
fossil right
oh i mean yeah i know that's where like
the whole like lord helix meme came from
yeah but like that's that's the extent
yeah i know there was like you know
they wanted more some people like a half
people wanted more order and half people
wanted the chaos
yeah and it was just like arguing and
stuff and it was quite interesting yeah
the only thing i remember from twitch
plays pokemon is
well they eventually finished it uh i
think they released their starter within
like
the first i think like hour or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're trying to sabotage yeah people
trying to see it and then obviously the
whole
helix thing but other than that like i
don't know
yeah at first when i heard about it i
was like oh i have to [ __ ]
go on to this and yeah participate in
some way right like i feel like i gotta
be part of this history yeah the moment
i went in and the
the chat is moving so [ __ ] fast where
it just looks like a blur i'm like
i remember i typed it never mind i'm
good i typed in the command and i was
like wow i didn't see it
yeah exactly i was trying to catch it
being like well i didn't see it
[ __ ] it whatever no because like i mean
there was like so many epic moments
created out of the most mundane
situations
like i i remember there was this one
ledge that took like [ __ ] eight hours
to cross
something like that and it was like the
most epic
ledge of water i think i watched that
collectively for like
three hours at least on my own time and
you know we we talk about
what is the mentality of people watching
someone sleeping and i'm just like wait
a minute i just watched three hours of
this
video game character trying to cross the
[ __ ] ledge i i haven't
i have i i can't act like i'm better
than anyone else because i [ __ ] did
that as well oh my god
we need like a category of competitive
gaming where it's like a team
does like everyone gets one button
like dark souls but everyone gets one
button each well actually one of my
friends uh
they're like a couple streamer and they
do split control secure
so one of them is on the mouse and the
other is on the keyboard and they beat
the whole game
on split controls i'm just like this is
the type of [ __ ] that's like
why why why would you subject yourself
to this pain i can
i could barely play sakura with both of
my own hands yeah yeah
let alone having the [ __ ] curry and
also like they managed to beat the whole
game without getting mad at one another
i'm like that's not how it works
that's scripted yeah scripted fake
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you two
have you seen that one twitch streamer
who like plays league of legends with
the most random inputs
uh is it ross boone's
yeah like we played league of legends
using bananas
as inputs yeah because i think it's
not that difficult because you just need
something that because there's only like
like really like four major buttons yeah
yeah so you just need to
have something that takes four inputs
you could literally do that with
anything
right right right but i mean that that's
that's why i think i've been watching
more stream content right now because i
think
to me as a youtube creator you know we
we watch a lot of youtube and i feel
like we can definitely see
the formula of good content on youtube
and it's rare
nowadays that i look at a youtube video
and i'm like wow that is uh that is
you're doing something really original
right now because because i mean
you know you know we had a few years ago
where missed the beast completely
revolutionized the platform yeah and now
it just feels like he's the one coming
up with the original ideas you know
mr beast like head and shoulders above
the rest yeah and i feel like
he's someone who is one was someone who
understood the platform
and two now has the resources to do the
craziest
ideas that literally no one else no one
else can think of
like who the [ __ ] just makes a [ __ ]
burger chain for content
right like who else can do that well
who else can [ __ ] ask when i saw that
video myself feed i was like
it's a rap guy it's like like he just
won the game